what's up everyone it's Warren and we
have some huge Avengers in-game leaks
today these are very official and they
reveal some new things including a few
new scenes in the movie now we have
already known about a few of these leaks
but now we have the pictures to back
them up but of course a couple of these
leaks are very new and very huge so I
must issue a spoiler alert for anybody
who does not want any spoilers for
Avengers in game you should click away
now also I picked a winner for my
giveaway yesterday but started a new one
as well so if you would like to enter my
giveaway for your chance to win five
imax tickets all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain okay so we have four Lego leaks
here all of which were on the German
Amazon page pre-order is available right
now but it seems like they will actually
go on sale April 1st of 2019 so the
FIRST LEGO League is the one that I've
done a video on before which is the War
Buster suit as you can see it's very
clear that war machine is going to get a
war Buster suit in Avengers in game and
like I said I did a video on this before
so I'll jump right past this the next
one is Captain America outriders attack
I did a video on this a while ago as
well the picture quality of the box was
not as good we get a little bit more
clarity here and as you can see Captain
America has his shield back he's writing
a huge motorcycle and the outriders are
back and like I said I've done a video
on this in the past as well so let's
move on to a new awesome leak the Iron
Man Hall of armor Lego set we have
gotten rumors of this leak before but
obviously this makes it official as you
can see he's got multiple Iron Man
armors there including a buildable Igor
armor marks 1-5 41 and 50 and there's
two outriders included in this set so
what does this tell us
well for starters this is at the
Avengers facility and Tony clearly makes
it back somehow which isn't really a big
surprise at all but it appears that Tony
Stark will use multiple Iron Man suits
in the film and the outriders will
attack I would love to see a scene with
old Iron Man suits in it especially if
Tony is using these suits for battle
now one thing to keep in mind is that
the rooster brothers said that these
leaks aren't always accurate the
outriders may not specifically be
attacking the ironman hall of armor room
they may have just put the outriders in
this to sell toys however this does
reveal to us that we will see Iron Man's
hall of armor room in Avengers in game
and we do know that the outriders will
attack the Avengers compound and
Avengers in game as well and we know
that from this leak and the next one
which is a massive fight at the avengers
compound as you can see feyo's is there
and he's fighting the Hulk Captain
Marvel Iron Man nebula and ant-man this
is a huge battle at the avengers
compound so we know that Thanos at one
point in time goes to the Avengers
compound we can see an outrider in the
background as well so that most likely
means that he brought his army with him
but look what he has in his hand he has
a massive hammer we've seen leaks where
he has a double bladed sword but we've
never seen him with a hammer this could
be coal obsidians hammer or this could
be something completely different but
he's clearly going to use it in a fight
against the Hulk so as we all expected
the Hulk and Thanos are going to get
their rematch this is going to be a very
huge battle as you can see some of the
turrets at the avengers compound are
firing against Thanos nebula is in a
helicopter fighting off the outriders
ant-man is in the background shrunken as
you can see it's a miniscule Ant Man
figure so he's probably up to something
and Iron Man Captain Marvel and the Hulk
are taking on Thanos now Fano still has
the gauntlet on in this set so why is he
using a hammer perhaps he doesn't have
all of the Infinity stones in this
battle and what's also interesting is
that not all of the Avengers are in this
scene perhaps the other Avengers such as
Captain America Thor war machine rocket
Black Widow etc are actually back in
time right now because if this is a huge
fight at the Avengers facility you would
expect them to be there or perhaps this
battle takes place in an alternate
reality we won't really know until the
movie comes out but we do know that
there will be a rematch between the Hulk
and Thanos and a huge battle at The
Avengers compound thanks to this leak so
that's it for these Lego leaks let me
know what you think about the scenes
that these Lego sets have revealed to us
let me know your thought
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers in game
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]